all right you're done let's look at the
solution as I said in the question we're
going to be working inside a forecast
fragment in the update weather function
first we're going to need to create a
standard intent for our alarm receiver
we then at our location query as an
extra we then wrap that at a pending
intent a pending intent is a special
kind of object that describes an intent
this allows other applications to
implement the feature of the original
intent that's used to create the pending
intent we're only going to use this
pending intent once so I set flag one
shot then we get the alarm service and
set the alarm to trigger five seconds
from now
but we still need for our alarm to do
something back in the broadcast receiver
we need to send the standard intent to
start our service and that's it let's
try running the app alright so now we've
got the alarm manager getting in the way
of our service we hit refresh it'll take
us about five more seconds before we
actually see the data now and there we
have it a very very simple alarm even
with this updating in the background
potentially and using a service we could
still be more efficient in our use of
phone resources rato can tell us more
about that